you have to shows you're very busy
things are going great you also have two
sons two kids also yeah they are they're
young yeah they're four and six four and
six boys that's an incredible amount of
work tell me about them what are they
into four in six I'm trying to remember
those ages what are they they're cute
they're really good friends now and
right now they're into teaming up
against me and like trick me or make me
laugh which is kind of cute but I
because of that I told him about April
Fool's Day which is now become their
favorite thing in the world so they're
just into tricking me
so last week my husband was out of town
when I put them both to bed I had them
all day by myself put them both to bed I
come downstairs I turned on bad TV I got
a glass of wine turn the lights down I
was just like in heaven and maybe 20 30
minutes goes by and all of a sudden I
feel a finger on the back of my neck I'm
alone in the house I freaked out and
turned around an axle standing there and
he goes I've been watching you the whole
time that's an April Fool's joke no it's
not fine that's just creepy I'm in
trouble he's a deaf does he do other
streams I can't even go there right
jeopardizing his future okay what about
saying inappropriate things because I
remembered my kids now don't do that but
when they were younger they would
occasionally like adults would be around
and they would say something and I'd be
like oh my no I want to die that's him
that's him so like his whole thing is
he's very misunderstood guys they're
really sweet kid yeah he tries to make
you laugh by saying things that are
really inappropriate which I can't fault
him for I mean both of his parents do
the exact same thing but right he's in
kindergarten and there's a little girl
in his class who she was telling her
friend that her dad is in the hospital
cuz he has pneumonia and like it was a
sudden thing and he goes I hope your dad
dies in the hospital Oh
that's a good job she's five and her
dad's actually in the hospital he's the
same one that touched you on the neck
and said I've been watching you oh my
god he's a beautiful kid I've hung out
with them yeah yeah dude he's gonna
spend some time in juvie he's a good kid
you'll learn things there and then we
constructive protect you
you